coming up for the first person of this
match
Frances very own he has been a
powerhouse throat just throw almost
every single toward McKeon Jersey's an
incredible competitor in timing time
again DC has nightmare coming to
fruition and body people knows here we
go crowds go with Keith Yackey earning
his invitation by way of winning Japan
actually Shanshan whom is in this hoppy
right but he is actually going to be
going up against the final round winner
Lolo mix who's gonna be coming down
right there there he is the Yoshimitsu
and a straw there we go reppin reppin
that I love it the finesse this man has
so solid yeah so I mean low low low low
was playing astronaut since I believe
three and then in four he was playing
Yoshimitsu and then
he's been doing them so so incredibly
challenging Mira has all of his friends
cheering at the top of their lungs yeah
but first let's go ahead and hear some
choice words from Lola mix everyone has
some patterns when when they played and
set ups so I try to learn this their
setups when they do something that could
hurt my character so encouraged thank
you because you meet with a short-range
character so you cannot with yeah that's
the scene with it with a short-range
character that's why the long-range
characters won't want you to do so
that's mainly what I
[Music]
jinks yo then that for you is low low so
we're so excited to see what match comes
up next who will he pick in this matchup
yeah so he's gonna have either
Yoshimitsu or a strata at his disposal
right I mean everybody's pretty ready in
terms of the Yoshimitsu and seeing
yoshimitsu right from him it's just been
so many damn years of yoshimitsu right
to the point where he's he's even
there's even a reference to Lola mixes
prowess in an extra battle in slow
caliber v if I remember correctly
but yeah so I he could do either our
nightmares
I feel like pretty guaranteed in terms
of Keith yeah so it's like it's like
watching magic basic it is so clean his
executions clean his movements if
everything you watch of him is so
beautiful and the amount that he adapts
within within a single round he is
incredible it's as if you studied an
entire match in one round of download so
that's what I'm excited to see as well
yeah it's really funny you actually use
the word magic because the way he
describes his own play style is he tries
to sprinkle and I quote a little bit of
grace is it something it's something
along those lines I mean but on the
other side Lola makes he's somebody who
he really likes to get into the
opponent's head and understand their
tendencies right so like maybe the first
couple of rounds and this in the set
could very well be like you'll see Lola
mixed do some very like just the same
things over and over again to see what
what keeps the tendencies might be and
then you just you'd see an explosive
difference after that to possibly just
be the straight-up download right it's
it's sucked okay yes okay yeah thing
Mina is in other carts of that he had
been playing so it's again not much of a
surprise here we go heading into game 1
between Keith and Lola
let's get it going I'm gonna get the to
be stage though so that that wall on the
left side might be a little odd but you
know you got to watch out for on the Sun
Mina ability to bring out near the
library yeah well I'll carry here we go
yeah get it poppin low low are you
looking mad damn it no bad damage right
now yeah already hidden keep out of a
revenge attack crying to the aga beyond
a neutron block right for a nightmare
plus 2 4 6 3 before nightmares neutral
so you got a you have to just check him
you have to challenge okay sitting back
look he gets the chair charts but he's
got such a life lead that he doesn't
want to see those toes baby let's go
okay oh we get the cameras off this
impact to the territory so want somebody
goes for the mix-up on that talk for the
plus' frames and okay clocks maybe to
get the 60 thrill with the mix-up
another MIT but there's a grand trine
coming out just in time before me seven
seconds like no the clock and he gets
kicked in his mouth watch yo team boy
get a mouth guard
all right Louis walking early on yeah 6p
is such a strong tool for nightmare
right sure not only is the contents of
adventure pack so it'll get in May on
it'll get him a revenge just agh yeah I
mean why not right if you're far enough
away
okay so charge activated though he's
gonna watch out because basically in
just constantly recharge state at this
point
oh wow then the kick actually just put
him out of range just by a little bit
and there's no lethal hit big damage
watches helper melt would you know what
Lulu not giving up on this bounce old
charging trying to bring it back yeah I
mean he's got to make something happen
now but there it is the card impact on
the bubble mama is dead Bubble Boy yeah
he gets the bar back right here because
it is a lot possible lap around for him
you know
okay trying to get the lethal hit again
on that one but the break attack is
horizontal gets the grab it is broken up
the front friend use as many revenge
attacks we can basically trying to get
you know Tara charged bubble to activate
okay I like this little charge basically
that gets em out of the part of the the
situation of closed ranks and I'm there
and that's not having to deal with the
mix-up tree took flapjack here but the
lot would a lot better than it would
have been a second ago okay Texas throw
ru comes out and here we go
this is your chance all right there you
go love getting on the board now but
don't forget we do you have keep your
wish
he's got yellow fleshy mortgage bill so
he could be couldn't put in a precarious
situation luckily because he gave me a
miracle he might be able to get himself
out trying any blocking flapjack oh my
god the bonnet rip I'm just saying keep
new team on that made a plane ticket
that's that one took that first game
timeout
his friends or his friends are yelling
to him you're leaning over the stage I
see yes see I can see Nova mage yeah it
looks like Nova majors omega dr yep you
know dominican republic boys helping
each other out right there you know i
guess i guess if he really wants it he
can call it skill you know get they get
that regional help they use their phone
a friend
blind blood phone this one yep problem
being though is you only have two
matches if you don't win this one right
here definitely possible unless maybe he
had messed up his original buttons in
the first place oh my oh no he might
have actually messed up his button to
originally a very very good chance on
that okay then dan hey I don't know he
was looking pretty confident in that
said especially directly afterwards you
know he thought someone who just show I
taught him emotion in the first place
but I I definitely felt an air of
confidence host that match
especially you can see it in the way he
plays he's so aggressive right now and
oh my god that was scary get off the
stage once he took that low that was a
true Palmer into the ring I'll install
keep mixing it up super super well gonna
be able to get the 1a right there grant
red comes out okay tack on the front
escape right there okay that does a lot
of damage so do that pretty early on
there's a really good idea by llola Oh
got a mid right there yeah a lot of fun
you know but they actually cancelled it
a night he was able to step the 6p
because of the cancel and they got the
launcher finished off the round low low
with the tricky stuff here we go both of
them for a lot of spacing more respect
to the surrounds but with a right AJ
coming in clutch super hard to the step
guard because of how fast it comes out
right like you're kind of covered with
stuff a lot of the time kind of an AGA
over on right there Oh bleep Oh ant but
there was a bit of too far away so was
able to get the corner carry that was
probably gonna ring out actually uh had
that she's been able to get that of the
full conversion unfortunately that does
actually leave a tip-- rage so really
cool buddy was able to get that spacing
properly for it too
okay nice to interrupt with the two-way
right there's gonna be able to delay
thanks so much are people so - Tara
Carter pH is a second one always able to
get the five sceptered the possible mix
up a jump out of it Wow
the other sign tip gets the throw and
that's got it to the round little mix
signs of light looking a lot better
that's the real question just know what
team does not meet it to work with yeah
I could it don't really hit that button
Shack I mean it's really unfortunate
that was it happened by I mean that's on
him right
hey yeah he is being very very
methodical about his approach he doesn't
do not want to take any big risks give
it a good the throw here okay cut the
low trying to mix them up with them it
but no ties well the mix was looking for
you John it could have managed damage on
him luckily they're gonna try to mix up
at he's able to get out of there quick
attack comes off 9k that's easily one of
them one of the best movies they might
not have
Wow each other nothing too crazy just
yet but don't forget damage to a plus B
here we go what's your okey-doke
Oh was able to Mac tech out of Italy
stop the EGA gets the launcher and Lolo
back up in it one to one at this point
and going to final matches each time
here we go
keep gonna stay a nightmare but we're
gonna get sage Slav that's real question
yeah well you know despite that t-that
stages volatility and then signs you
know where problems would have a lot
better ring out that didn't come up but
I could totally understand why you would
go for a stage stop here yeah here we go
actually on so this stage does have a
cool property about it the walls do
break after three hits so let's see them
changed color
wait turns red that means it's on its
final hit
give you a little a second yeah so a lot
of people will actually only hit the
first hit they kind of do a different
column or they don't get along it
because most curtains can keep you
putting on the pressure and they're
gonna get this territory away okay no GI
represented on it and we filled in GI
the first time as well drew the second
time now let's check right
gave it a counter hit on it so he you
stopped them from pressing whatever it
was for it's not in that game going to
keep with a lot more pressure than
wasn't the previous game you know we'd
like this were thing from before right
stocking up step party whose check it
whereas like that last round ran out of
space true look at those guards press it
by a little right now excellent job it
there we go keep still has been noted to
work with one beat there's the plus
frames okay so low cards coming out
don't want to see what the mix-up right
also you know it's just sullen strong
all but what a wonderful step there from
Lola checking it out one mix-up away the
aga gets bodies where the low okay one
to one in rounds right now and remember
this is the last game here you have a
loser this is dropped into loser side so
in the tournament but you have to make
quite a run just walk and then punish on
that table to escape that flap back
start up the sole charge and this is
where something it could be soul so
scary access to amid that is just about
the same amount of damage in their world
oh here we are
old made rocket of mad damage oak
repositioning though oh we won some
peace okay and then got the horizontal
right there now low low on set point a
man said these shoes are too fresh don't
be touching on them okay
dokin Scott's oh don't I HEA again yeah
he's definitely sniff out when he
okay here we go but not today double
down on it all right
you know it's just straight up pressure
right able to walk into the factory
charge one's out right now Lobo has
definitely represented the sweep a lot
more than most that I see just in
general but I mean it works out so much
Frank the show gets full charges
those were his pressure games it really
comes into play Oh damage
okay a ga comes out and there it is the
horizontal to catch him again and Lolo
taking it over
he's moving on to the winners racket
absolutely wild
so take the game like that Wow and after
we watch the first match real do you
know what is it looking kind of into
favor but do you know what Beaulieu
brought that spice every single time
incredible actually one time well lookey
with his candies Oh try these out like
they're like they're from Mexico they're
super great they I died I died
temporarily my soul actually left my
body through my mouth and I I felt was
gonna pass out but you know what that's
that's that kind of like